I'm Hugh Grant I'm Michelle Rodriguez
I'm Chris Pine and this is the wired
complete incomplete I got this i got
this and this is the wired complete
[Applause]
[Music]
why don't you have him say it he's the
best no no no no no no this is the wired
autocomplete interview
[Music]
what made Chris Pine famous Star Trek
the first one and the first week that it
came out when there were Paparazzi
outside of my tiny apartment that I was
living at on Silver Lake Boulevard it
was a very uh eye-opening experience
next one
how is Chris Pine alive in Wonder Woman
1980s oh
um
um because
um we might have some simpler ones
I know this I know this I know this I
know there's like a stone of um
there's a stone of some sort there's a
stone of some sort and it was wished
upon and then and then I came back that
really clears that up
legendary grandmother this is an easy
one and Gwen was my mom's mom came out
to Los Angeles in the 30s and worked at
Republic pictures and Universal she was
a screamed Queen and then she ended up
being uh she was at Bullocks at the hair
Department she was the secretary for
years
they're called pine nuts
[Laughter]
many Chris Pine
Star Trek is that an English what does
that mean
how many Chris playing Star Trek how
many Chris Pine Star Treks I've made
Three Star Treks I've been involved in
Three Star Treks hopefully many more
what is Hugh Grant's favorite film Hugh
Grant ever yes Sound of Music it's a
difficult situation I'm married to a
Swedish woman who comes from the North
of Sweden where men are really men
they're so manly they hardly speak and
they chop wood what they don't do is
watch The Sound of Music in the
afternoons and sing along with the
Mother Superior when she sings Climb
Every Mountain and they certainly don't
cry when uh the father Christopher
Plummer is touched by his children
singing and then joins in but I do cry
but it's impeccable the film is
impeccable it's not a single moment I
don't love and I sometimes go to those
uh you know you can have a whole party
where you you screen the film and
everyone dresses up as characters I
think it was Elton John's 60th was like
that I went as the baroness
wow
okay great what is Hugh Grant's last
line in in Love Actually uh unwatchable
um
no no don't know oh yes I do know I
think I improvised it so she jumps into
my arms at the airport and I say God you
wear tongue
what did you grant study at Oxford
wow English literature fat lot of good
that did me
but I didn't do much of that towards the
end I became a socialite really I went
to parties and was pretentious nothing
much has changed yeah okay
is Hugh Grant reading in Notting Hill in
that nauseating moment on the bench at
the end I'm reading uh
Captain Corelli's mandolin by Louis
which was going to be his next film so
it's a little in joke from Roger
Michelle God Rest his soul and now
passed away what movie was Hugh Grant
and Meryl Streep in we made a film
called Florence Foster Jenkins in which
she plays the worst singer in the world
it was a true story I play her sort of
husband slash manager slash possibly the
man who sort of used her a bit you're
not quite sure whether I'm good or bad
that's the genius of my performance
you're not quite sure everyone else is
though I enjoyed it and I think Meryl
learned a lot from watching me
yeah
yeah well Michelle what kind of car do
you drive Tesla
when does Michelle Rodriguez appear in
Lost
oh I have no idea I'm on the horrible
calendar person but uh I did in the
second season I think I was a little
disappointed they went the Bible route I
was expecting them to go maybe a little
more sci-fi black hole you know
rosenbridge you know Vibes but they they
kind of went Bible with it so but it's
okay it was still fun
how many Resident Evil movies
is Michelle uh two
two I only did two because I died in the
first one
and they only brought me back to life
once and then killed me again it was a
clone thing you know I'm always being
brought back to life in movies I don't
know why this happens they always kill
me they're like she doesn't have a
boyfriend we don't know what the purpose
of this strong female you know is I
really want you back fans really want
you back afterwards yeah it's a good
sign it is a good sign yeah I mean but
you know why kill me in the first place
they're so mean misogynist I guess Q do
you have any more questions show us your
Dead face
it's really difficult dead yeah
I'd go with open eyes well
yeah
that's terrifying now come back to life
oh and she's gone
very difficult okay here we go here we
go how long to play Dungeons and Dragons
I don't know if there's like a time
limit you can play it for as long as you
want and I think some campaigns go on
for quite a long time can you play
Dungeons and Dragons is that the next
one it's the next one all right yeah yep
bye yep
what's the next one
yourself by yourself you absolutely
can't I don't think you can play dungeon
dragons by yourself but I think the
whole thing about it is that you play
with other people and uh it's a jam it's
a good time let's play we got it we've
got to play we're coming to the end of
knowing each other and we've never
played why are we coming to the end of
knowing each other well the film's
coming out and yeah but there could be
more films so can you die in Dungeons
and Dragons I think you can yeah yeah
you can yeah and then you create another
character yeah I died before ah right
now how Dungeons and Dragons works
there's dice involved you have to choose
a character are we talking about the
game yeah the games again the game no I
do
and you go on campaigns and um do you
dress up you can you can sure could I be
the baroness yes
okay what
what is the plot of the new Dungeons and
Dragons movie we can't say the whole new
plot but essentially a gang of uh
thieves and a Motley Crew of Ruffians
managed to unleash unleash this secret
evil power
yeah
I mean which evil power
he's in denial maybe but we're not ready
now to give away the plot anyway
we're delightful yeah yeah okay how's
Dungeons and Dragons fun I'll tell you
what
it is fun I well I haven't seen it yet I
see it tonight but um
I I hate all script I thought it was a
very funny script I thought it was like
Monty Python
but with moving bits and
um and you know if you like Monsters and
Dragons there's a very good fish that
eats babies or something
[Laughter]
let's see thank you
does Chris Pine do BMW commercials oh my
God
that's a good question do you do BMW
commercials yes I do do BMW commercials
for 12 years uh the voiceover oh wow
what would you say what do I say I say a
lot of things you it's a lot of things
about the cars okay does Chris Pine have
a flip phone uh I do not anymore
unfortunately have a flip phone I gave
it up which is very hard I really like
my flip phone but I find that I think
2022 makes it very difficult to be
analog the main issues that I was trying
to do group text with my friends and and
on my flip phone if you had a group text
going on you would send if a text came
in it wouldn't be in the group text it
would be from every single person on the
group text and be the same text long
story short it was just too difficult
but I do miss it it is Chris buying shy
I would say 50 50 introvert extrovert is
pie and really
release to the Woods that is actually
Chris Pine's voice
what does that mean Chris Pine likes to
sing what does it mean into the woods
into the woods is uh sometime musical
yeah oh our Chris Pine's eyes really
that blue Chris Brown's eyes are blue
Chris finds eyes are uh our book
who does Hugh Grant play in Paddington I
play it yeah Paddington 2 the better of
the two many people's opinions I'm the
the Baddie and he's uh he's a actor a
great London thespian called Phoenix
Buchanan who uh turns out to be rather
evil anyway children love it and I well
I say that I took my children to the
very first screening ever of it and at
the end of it they just said why are you
in it so much
that was odd then I took my ancient
father old military man to a bit
confused to the premier at Leicester
Square and halfway through he turned him
and he said is that a real bear
I said well no dad because he's he's
talking
anyway he thought it was marvelous
actually it's a very well reviewed film
it's the second best reviewed film ever
on Rotten Tomatoes does Hugh Grant
actually sing in music and
oh sorry lyrics yes I well I do but
I'm auto-tuned beyond belief actually
that's not true I'm auto-tuned a bit but
um not as much as some I I Drew
Barrymore was in that film with me and I
don't think she'd mind me saying her
singing is just horrendous
I've heard dogs oh snap spark better
than she sings
having said that once they tuned her up
she sounded way better than me because
she's got heart and voice and rock and
roll whereas I sounded like Julie
Andrews and I'm meant to be kind of rock
and roll as well does she Grant know
sign language I did learn sign language
for Four Weddings and a funeral because
I have these touching scenes with my
brother who's deaf in that film can Hugh
Grant tap dance well yes I I tap dance a
little bit at the end of Paddington too
can Hugh Grant play oh yeah I know can
you play tennis I do play but I'm a very
very angry player I mean really horrible
there's I was thinking the other day why
does no one ask me to play and it's
because I'm so unpleasant I imitate the
other player if I think they're not
really playing proper tennis and just
nudging it around I nudge it around as
well they're playing Moon balls like
Moon balling the Frenchman walked off
the court the other day he said you know
if you don't want to play we don't have
to play huh
no he didn't yeah he did no I'm not nice
uh
they're really great
Michelle who did you play in Avatar
Trudy chicone a helicopter pilot who do
you play in Fast and Furious I play
Leticia Ortez a kid from uh from Los
Angeles uh who grew up in the race race
car scene and she used to live on the
other side of the tracks and now works
with the government on and off when
they're not mad at her or her team she
gets to do really cool stuff around the
world
are you a boxer I uh played a boxer uh
Diana Guzman um in my first feature film
called girl fight I was an independent
film it was the thesis of the director
uh Karen kusama it basically took her
six years to get it off the ground
because all the producers that she tried
to make the movie with
basically wanted the guy to win at the
end even though the thing was Loosely
based on Lucia Riker winning a Golden
Gloves fight against a guy she made this
movie and it was fun so in mailboxing
you're not allowed to hit below the belt
in female boxing I'm often wondered this
are you allowed to hit a girl in the
booze yeah they wear these cups so it
protects the tip so you can hit them you
can you can totally punch them as hard
as you want right in the tits yeah
knock them right there you know just
keep pounding it out as much as you want
that's awful I know right
do you do your own stunts only when they
let me you know I'm not as lucky as Tom
Cruise or Jackie Chan the insurance
throughout the years has become a lot
more responsible and as it's become more
responsible they've allowed me to do a
lot less so I don't drive cars anymore I
just pull them in you know I don't do
extraordinary fight sequences I just
land or do the drop Resident Evil had
some wild stuff boy the gun rules in
Germany before they were part of the EU
let me tell you it was fun
I mean you got to shoot mp5s you know
like no joke at the range I almost took
people's head off and SWAT Sam Jackson I
remember him ducking behind me because
because of the guns I really loved
everything I've done and I trained
really hard for it with all the guns and
all the fighting choreography so yeah
if you ride a motorbike I did I used to
drive a Ducati but I just sold it took
me a while to learn to use it because my
brother lost his arm on a bike while I
was getting my license
and so it took me like a year to get the
the
courage to to ride a bike again once I
did you know I I did did some writing in
in uh in in Scotland I did some writing
and in New Zealand and it was fun I did
a couple hundred miles on both places
and I think you know that's enough for
me
[Music]
hopefully that we were a good time right
now
watching this
oh
I could apologize
I'm sorry uh is that Honesty yeah but
you'll like the film
foreign
[Music]